I said Davey's here with us to talk
about all sorts of things but primarily
of course the Northern Ireland protocol
what would you like to see in any deal
well I want to make sure we sort out the
trading relationships liberal Democrats
want to make sure there is a deal
because that would be good for Northern
Ireland it'd be good for the whole of
the UK economy the government's failure
to deliver a deal for months years now
has been a real break on economic
success so if the deal makes sense the
Democrats go back here and what does
making sense look to the liberal
Democrats
we need to make sure that the barriers
to trade are got rid of that there is a
deal that all parties can sign up to we
talked to parties in Northern Ireland a
lot to make sure we're getting the
Grassroots opinion from businesses and
people of Northern Ireland and our
sister party the alliance are very keen
on a deal we take that into huge
consideration because they and the
people they represent the most affected
by it so we'll be listening to people in
Northern Ireland but we also need to
take account of British business as well
sure I mean the alliance party in the
dup very different views on what should
be in this deal uh the dup saying they
don't want any Border in the Irish sea
brexit means there has to be a border
somewhere
well indeed that is the logic of of
brexit and the danger is that if we
don't sort this out the level of
investment in Northern Ireland the
investment in our own country uh we'll
just go down and down and down and let's
face it our economy is in a mess at the
moment we at the bottom the league for
growth I regret to say because of this
government's failed economic policies
and that's bad for people it's part of
the reason why people are finding it so
hard to make ends no but you're taking
me away from my point this morning um if
I may have said and that is what is
going to happen with the dup primarily
and thus the ERG
European research group they do not want
to border in the Irish sea what we're
being told is that there will be or be a
soft border but there will be a border
in the Irish sea well you're absolutely
right the dup and many conservative back
Ventures have been quite ideological
about this they're not being pragmatic
and I think when you listen to business
people and to the represent other
representatives in Northern Ireland they
want a pragmatic solution they want to
move on it seems the conservative party
is just incapable of doing that and
that's very damaging to our reputation
it's very damaging for our economy so I
hope there can be agreement with the dup
and the ERG from the conservatives
coming on board we'll see if Rishi sunak
has managed that what he can know is he
puts a reasonable deal on the table
there were Democrat MPS will support
that even if his conservative uh
supposedly colleagues vote against him
you might not get a saying it he doesn't
need to take it to Parliament he doesn't
absolutely need to in terms of
constitution but I think politically he
needs to I think most MPS if not all MPS
and certainly voters would think it'd be
extraordinary for him to do this huge
deal and not to allow the Electoral
representatives of people's
representatives to have a say
managed to get this
for the European Union and people like
Liz truss and Boris Johnson have not
we'll I will see what he puts forward
the deal we'll be scrutinizing it line
by line of course that's our job
um I just hope he has made found some
pragmatic Way Forward it's so damaging
not to have this deal and sometimes
people will think well it doesn't really
matter it's Northern mind it does matter
not just to the people of Northern
Ireland but to our ability to move on in
our relationship with Europe that's been
very damaging this this ampass over
Northern Ireland it's prevented us
enabling many of our businesses to have
better entry into the European uh
economy and that's hampering our our
wider success as a as an economy so we
really need a deal we need it soon and
the failure of the conservatives whether
it's been Johnson trust and now soon act
to deliver that has been a real failure
of government Sir Robert Buckland a
conservative previous cabinet secretary
now on the Northern Ireland select
committee saying to a certain level
has managed to get further than the
other two because of Personality
politics
quite possibly and to be honest that's
up to the conservatives so there seems
to be a battle between Personalities in
the casertis and the reason why I think
that's very reprehensible and wrong is
there are millions of families and
pensions out there who are suffering
suffering with the cost of living
suffering with energy bills and little
Democrats keep arguing the government
should should focus on the issues that
matter to people whether it's the cost
of living energy bills whether it's the
NHS crisis and the government keeps
taking its eye of the ball and seem
completely out of touch with the real
problems that people are facing to that
end you are suggesting a bonanza bonus
what's that all about well there's a
bonanza bonus being enjoyed by the
bosses of the oil and gas companies and
we think that that should be taxed along
with the windfall tax on the profits the
flips out of the win full tax okay yeah
because you know we need more help for
people struggling with energy bills and
the government at the moment despite
millions of people uh struggling are
proposing to increase People's Energy
bills by another 500 pounds this April
they you know in my decision is what
people who who can't afford their rent
we're seeing a large number of uh large
increase in the numbers of people going
to food banks that's the reality and yet
the government are going to increase the
cost of living what liberal Democrats
are saying is no we actually should be
cutting uh the energy bills for people
they're not
um increasing the the bills by 500
pounds what they're doing is taking away
um a temporary support structure that
was in place no well the support
structure called the energy price
guarantee is currently two and a half
thousand pounds which means the average
household will pay only two and a half
thousand pounds only huge amount the
conservatives proposing despite this
cost of living emergency to increase it
to three thousand pounds some people
will actually see their energy bills go
up by 900 pounds with this conservative
package so what liberal Democrats are
saying is no use the money that you have
saved government that you could put
aside for this uh support but keep it
there and if you do and you have a
proper info tax you can afford both to
cut everyone's energy bills by a lot by
reducing the energy price guarantee and
give more money to businesses who are
struggling and indeed the least well off
so we have a complete package properly
funded completely affordable which would
cut inflation and boost growth
is economics after all then no know
let's trust as economics were to give
the better off a lot more money we're
not doing that our money will be
targeted at the least well support with
our energy bills well her scheme was
just not affordable because you saw uh
the huge increase in borrowing what Alf
alphan is Affordable our proposals are
affordable because we use the money that
Jeremy Hunt put aside but he wants a
screw it away in the treasury we're
saying keep it there to help people with
their energy bills talk to me about
um Dominic Robb um he says that if he is
found guilty as far as bullying claims
are concerned then he will resign
I think you should if he's found guilty
um we all await the report I think we've
all been shocked by the number of
complaints but I think it's only fair to
to see what the investigation finds
because previously you had suggested had
you not that he should step aside until
the report yeah and I still think that
um I I think it's been quite wrong that
as Justice secretary Above All Justice
secretary he's been serving there
despite these huge number of complaints
I think in any other Walk of Life people
will have had to step down during the
investigation I think it's been wrong
that he's been in his post during this
very serious investigation and just
before that you go how do you think the
lib Dems are going to get on in Scotland
now that Nicholas sturgeon is stepping
aside
well you know Nicholas sturgeon I think
has admirers from across the parties
um she was the first woman uh first
minister in Scotland and while I and my
little Democrats disagree with her on
many many issues one couldn't help
admire the fact that she got to where
she she was
um the implications I think though for
the liberal Democrats are pretty
positive we're finding on the doorstep
that not just because Nicholas
sturgeon's stood down but the smp's
failures in government in Hollywood more
generally a lot of support is coming to
us in places like Edinburgh it's like
the Highland and Islands we're seeing a
big uptake in support for the liberal
Democrats coming from former SMP
supporters and former conservative
supporters okay are you a movie girl a
moviegoer well during the short recess I
went to see Puss in Boots The Last Wish
with my daughter
it was great fun she really enjoyed it
good apparently the one to watch is
everything everywhere all at once yeah
no I saw that I was gonna go I don't I'm
not sure I'll take my daughter to see it
though I wouldn't